[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record
we talking about whatever we wanted hi
anthony
what up anthony everyone likes having
anthony back
hi i like being back i know it's because
i can't travel anymore that's why i've
been around so i'm very thankful to not
travel to be around
for this particular room oh it's because
you have nothing else better to do so
you decided to come over here like a
constellation prize
yeah i heard that keep it coming keep it
coming i heard we were plan b
or whatever or like second place but
it's okay but plan b
saves a lot of relationships
it was really good that was good
especially because it came from like
her personal experience yep yeah
job dude um you know i've been getting a
lot of like messages of just
people like saying you need to have
anthony on more like they
dm me just to say that i thought this is
going towards the plan b
direction but yes okay yeah yeah really
you're becoming a priority
and then usually i have i don't have
faith in people
that can they can do a whole day
and then they can do multiple days only
a few can do it because people don't
know that we'd be filming from like
10 to like six six or six or seven times
yeah yeah non-stop talking we just get
one hour lunch
and then the whole day we're filming i
know we used to do two hours what
happened to that and we used to do like
uh
from like nine to like nine or so it was
like nine to nine now yeah
these are crazy times yeah i remember
leaving here like at two am once
and i was like that's a true yeah but
those days we did like 40
videos plus we would film during lunch
remember that yeah
and not only will we film we would all
vlog
true this is true you guys had the big
cameras too i remember david had like
the giant like tripod still stuck to his
giant dslr he's like this is the best
way to vlog for sure
yeah dang i was actually thinking about
i feel like i've been doing jk news with
you guys for like
six years well you've been messing with
jk for a long time even during the skit
days and
what yeah when did jk news start uh nine
or eight years ago
[Music]
12 or 13. yeah nine or eight years ago
right i feel like i might have been here
right before it started because it was
me and lawrence was doing all those
skits
the really masculine roles i forgot like
the best
hero hetero roles i remember i don't
know why
bart always wrote you guys into doing
the most romantically
i knew it i told you no this is what we
brought this up many times ago
what would happen you always write the
the rules like that he's like no dude
you guys are natural
because i would produce it and and they
would never ask for you guys to
pretend kiss or smell it doesn't even
say that
it's very suggestive no like it's like
you put all the ingredients into a
blender and you're like what kind of
what kind of blender are you getting
you know what i mean like you guys
always over delivered though for sure
we there was a lot of pressure it was
really strong
specifically this the skit it was
either like lauren's need to reach
something from a higher cabinet
and you just need to help him he's in
the script
and then so that's what i wrote in the
script after he
got what he needed look at his fingers
look at the position of his finger got
what he needed
lawrence turns around and then puts his
legs now
and then i was like what the [ __ ] all
right
i'm like i guess this is what they like
to do i'm gonna write to your strengths
and then
so all the other skits i started writing
to what you guys are known for yeah and
then we were like
damn nothing will beat no matter what
okay see
that is easy like male comfort you know
course
friendliness all that stuff you know
we're dancers motorboating balls
whatever
but nothing's still going to be i think
it was the the bobby lee skit
oh yeah when bobby leaves in his script
in his skit it's not our skit anymore
that's bobby skit dude
okay cause cause that's when that's when
i was like what is the script writing
he goes off script yeah he's making his
own that's his own skit now
he was at i think you're you guys old
house um in monterey park and
it was the one where he like just puts
his hand oh no that's her house
that was your place that's right and he
started playing with himself
you were there too yeah and he just
starts
you know playing with himself i guess
yeah but again i thought it was like i
was like oh man this guy's really
dedicated yeah it was real
and then like six seconds later it's
like man he's really dead
you know what i mean in the beginning i
was like oh this is what hollywood
training is this is that hollywood
training i've been hearing about
and then i'm like nah this is just him
jacking off
yeah it was at the 30 city i was like
way late afterwards i was like
oh i don't think i was there for that
one it turned yeah no
i wasn't there so the scene is him to
motion like he's jacking off
so he just has to stick his hand under
his hand and his underwear and this
movie he started touching himself
he's the method acting this full he goes
he spits on his hand
like legit of a loogie he goes down
and he starts moaning and touching
himself like no one else is in the room
wow i gave him props and i'm like what
the and then you shook his hand after he
was
absolutely you know it seemed like
acting because you know their camera's
there
not he was by himself no so he does that
and it was like the first take and then
he goes i'm not doing that again so i
hope you got it
yeah yeah and he does it again i'm gonna
do that the scene
said 30 seconds i think casey was like
alright this is gonna be a really quick
scene we're just gonna it's a cutaway
and he touched himself for like 10-15
minutes
he gets up and like no one even asks you
to do at the beginning he always does
that
remember when he phantom sucked your
dick and he put his face
right in front of your crotch oh yeah
with that skit with gina
yeah yeah yeah wow he didn't even ask
he was well bart was like a handyman or
a plumber or some [ __ ]
and then bobby just put his face on his
crotch and he was like a centimeter away
and he started sucking air sucking it
you should just kiss again and invite
poppy i know right
yeah i i i have ptsd from that but you
know
you know i will never forget the image
yeah yeah that's why i don't remember
you're there because it was just me and
bobby
i don't remember anyone else i didn't
remember anthony because i was just like
looking at
bobby the whole time and i don't even
remember who else was on set that same
we all have that moment in time burned
in our brain that's all it was
and the whole time i kept thinking i'm
like that's my couch
that was actually that was actually
maybe the first time that i was like
wondering i was like
in terms of like my being a part of the
jk fam i was like man this is the deep
zone
like you want to be fam you got to be
like you've got to be willing to play
with yourself
yeah but you know seeing some of your
guys's face afterwards i was like okay
maybe not
maybe there is a line we were all pale
and [ __ ]
do you think in terms of artists there's
a hierarchy of
like craziness so you know like for
example like like
like i think like like rappers and maybe
like leading actors right they they got
i gotta i gotta be cool
so i'm not really down to like touch my
dudes in a certain way or like you know
do things and i think as you move down i
think dancers are like you know i'm like
i'm kind of like moving around and [ __ ]
so like i'm
i think done it gets down to like maybe
stand-up comedians or sketch comedians
like the
what they're willing to do it's it gets
crazier and crazy i don't know if
there's like
you're talking about the level of no
shame are you talking about no shame
that's a wonderful
is up here like the top uh like
most sane or like where are you at i
think the most
self-conscious is is it and then two
that might be that's another way to look
at it is that is that like that yeah
cause like there's there's dudes that
are like in the fitness industry i've
worked with that are like
super like i'm the next rock type of
dude and then i'll ask them just to do a
little bit you know step outside
boundaries is what i think and then like
nah i'm doing that
i ain't doing that [ __ ] it's kind of
like i got a reputation to uphold
yeah i'm like i'm bobby lee and i'll
take a dump on the street corner
in my own car dude i think he's an
anomaly i think that there are many
anomalies but
i don't think that that could be a
generalized category well there's tom
green
too it's a very small pool nuts
yeah like off camera i think so
like the [ __ ] that they talk about and
the [ __ ] they're willing to do yeah i
think comedians are pretty crazy
so the dancers are crazier because
because you and lawrence do some crazy
[ __ ]
nah man i think we're totally just
flirting with the lion you know what i
mean we love each other
thank you dancers are very woke man
they're very considerate of other people
because they're they're used to working
in a group
so they're like you all right over there
okay they do it yeah
i think i think there are subcategories
in like the dance world like b-boys are
like the most like
raw like you know their entire culture
is like super badass
are very wrong in their movement but
they're i've seen b-boys just be like
a lot of people are just like party b
boys you know they're just like really
fun really cool dudes but like i don't
see that i don't see crappers getting
all like as de-gaff is like the kind of
notions that we're talking about i agree
with b-boys because b-boys is like
dancing and extreme sports so you have
to [ __ ]
jackass of dance you know like they're
crazy you guys got
you know b-boys doing like naked
headspans and air flares and like little
you know
it's like a sprinkler with a dick
that can just because and they'll be in
the middle of a club where you
literally saw someone just throw up on
the floor
and spill drinks and but if they start
feeling hype
like oh [ __ ] they start creating their
[ __ ] circle i'll round the throw up
and they gotta [ __ ] start going and
i'm like dude you have like a 200
shirt on are you really gonna spin on
that pile of throw up and they're down
i heard that oxiclean is pretty good if
you clean up the throw up on your
clothes
that's true because so ty doesn't really
throw up that much
but he does love ice cream like me so he
always eats ice cream and gets it all
over the place
and when he eats the chocolate ice cream
that's the stuff that's really really
hard
to get out and especially if you just
you know clean them up and you throw the
clothes to the side
it'll soak in and then it kind of ruins
as close and baby clothes i don't know
why
they're kind of expensive even though
they're really small so we like to use
oxiclean and there's a stick that you
can just rub it in and then you can
what's so funny dude
they're really small they are really
small and it's very expensive you're
right yeah
because he's small yeah so with the new
oxiclean
uh max force they either have the spray
or they have the stick and
the spray one is really cool cause you
spray it on it just soaks in and just
leave it and then later on when you wash
it it comes out completely so it's
really good if you got like pets and
kids because it removes
grass stains blood stains chocolate and
we also got the stick one that i really
like it's almost like a deodorant stick
and you can just rub it on
and that's why i like oxycodone so do
you put the stick on and then you throw
it in the washing machine
um the stick one is more for like if
it's like a in a place where i can't
just spray it on and let it soak and i
kind of want to rub it out a little bit
and i use a stick so
if you want to try oxiclean
max force for yourself max horse okay to
work your magic with oxiclean
go to oxyclean.com maxforce1
to get a coupon for one dollar off baby
i'm gonna leave a link right in the
description box below so you can check
that out
one dollar off baby there we go that's
why it's called max force one
have you been following soy tea
i have man dude your push-up video the
other day
man that music calories on point you
guys don't know
okay who doesn't know do you don't know
i saw from your instinct
you don't know i know now yeah
the national treasure of vietnam this is
his this is his thing
okay are you proud
22 24
25 26.
that's so funny it reminds me of me when
i was a kid and i used to like want to
sing but i didn't know lyrics i would be
using numbers and letters
this dude is saying he didn't want to be
seen this dude is no he's singing
yeah yeah yeah so this this is the first
auto tunes his own
like when i first listened to it i was
laughing right so i think this feels
like william hung he's like hilarious he
doesn't know how
like crazy he's sounding and then i
started listen i bought a song
i started listening to it on repeat like
for three hours straight
and i'm like wait this guy is actually
very musical
doing numbers he doesn't repeat the
melody doesn't repeat the rhythm like he
has good flow like he has a song where
he goes like
41 42 43 40. so that the 43 already
changed the phrasing on that
44 45
i'm like damn this fool is like he did a
full
eight bars without without uh any
repetition or anything i'm like dude
this guy is i don't know if he knows
what he's doing
but he's actually really good would you
be trying to make a song with him
because you guys haven't made music in
so
long i think he's way above my level i
know if snoop dogg's like promoting his
[ __ ] then i don't know
he is yeah i can't wait till he gets
into the
thousands though i want to i think this
whole plan i was telling bart
is he hit the hundreds already no he's
in the 40s
i think his whole plan is because it
started off with
one yeah like and then he has like one
to like 10.
he starts off with one and then like
somewhere else you'll see like 12 to
like 15 or some [ __ ]
that's the name of the song it's like
the number no no no no no no no just his
instagram like
it's just it's in progression right the
one you can get on itunes is called
doing numbers
but that one starts at like 30 something
to 40 or so
that's volume he's like now this is what
i call soy tip volume
683 just like 30 years from now you know
that's what i think he's gonna do is
when he hits a hundred
he's gonna compile it all as one song
from one to a hundred he's never gonna
run out of lyrics
i know well he'll run out after a
million right
no you just keep going but the song will
just be so long 1 million 9096
564.3
one billion and one one billion
once it's a trillion then it could be
like brian mcknight and he'd be like
back at what
two three it starts to be all over again
i like his his week though man monday
tuesday
that one's the best oh he doesn't think
he has brand deals yeah oh yeah you want
to do a
barbell brandy yeah i just want to send
him a gear and like because
dude this [ __ ] did one where he was
like if your cash is low
you don't got money at home and he's
like
what was the debt collection
so he's singing his brand deals too yeah
i bet he's getting like 50 bucks he's
just going ham on it
it's just worth it it's worth it just to
get him some gear
and like he's pursuing his passions and
getting paid for it yeah
and it's like dude these numbers were
useful in school yeah
he starts doing equations and then like
next thing you know he's like huge and
he's just equal m squared that's when
his fans just drop
him no no no state accounting dude yeah
he goes to complicated
one half three false fractions of [ __ ]
just saying though
i became a fan at number 16 when he
dropped number 16
specifically there was he was just
singing a song he's like
11 12 13 14
15 60
this is my dude for sure he's good
you know for every single track though
he's using the same chord progression
the same chord
yeah oh really it's the same one stick
to what you know whether yeah
it's it's working for him well i think
it's like the chord progressions are
just
90s vietnamese music because i could
also hear zambanda
but he just put her place the [ __ ] is
this
he's in the studio dude he's it's about
the studio mindset this is his rice hat
that's it you know what's crazy he looks
like a 40 year old man that has a 12
year old body
that hangs out with kids you don't mean
like vietnamese
huh no have you seen him playing soccer
with all the other kids like so he has
his voice
of a 13 year old but i feel like he's
40.
you do look 40. yeah his teeth at least
look forward i know right
he only has eight teeth i think he's
like that jungle uncle you know what i
mean the jungle uncle
like you know how in the jungle every
like in the village if you go to one oh
yeah
y'all hang out but he's the jungle uncle
like he's kind of not cool
to be with the adults but then he has
like he's like cool to the junior high
kids he's like bawling now though he's
gonna pin people out right
for sure he's gonna run his whole street
i see him with a
uh with a cigarette dangling out of his
mouth crouching and and maybe with a
beer so yeah in a flip-flop
yeah put a bet right now how many people
here think his manager is going to screw
him over
oh i think so i hope not i really hope
not
but yeah you're right exactly his
brother nah
oh but he's going to screw him over if
it's his brother oh okay
it's like he's probably getting brand
deals for like five grand and then he
gets paid a hundred bucks
the manager's page looks like someone
that was like oh shoot this guy's coming
up
i could jump on this real quick doesn't
look like someone's very experienced
what i'm hoping though is my buddy in
vietnam he's um
trying to get in contact with him and i
hope that he could
help him out and be the one to [ __ ] him
over instead of this random person
way to have your friends back no no i
hope that he catches them
and meets them and and and and schools
them on entertainment and [ __ ]
because that is a thing where a lot of
people get caught up with bad managers
you know what [ __ ] tripped me out so
his new song doing numbers
the one that i bought i'm such a big fan
of newest hit yeah his newest hit i was
like alright cool i'm gonna make a
instagram video to that song and then i
was in imovie
on my phone and when i try to import
that song that song is copyright
protected oh my god this [ __ ] is
registering his music and doing
everything legit
oh my god i can't even help promote them
so i have to play when i did the push-up
video
i had to do it in the gym like play it
through the speakers
and welcome to my whole world like
instagram story you know how you could
add songs
in your uh story oh you can oh yeah now
that it's wrong oh if this song's
actually in
apple music oh right right right yeah
you see everyone else getting super
hyped up while working out too they're
like yeah 43 44.
the minute i turned on the song everyone
i mentioned looked at
like what the [ __ ] and i think when they
saw it like oh it's bart doing his weird
[ __ ]
this guy's just doing 23.
it's a good song to work out too at
least it's counting the reps i know
right
wait what the [ __ ] does it start with
41.
it starts in the 40s that's even better
that's your guy's perfect collab right
there
you know he just makes a barbell track
that's specifically for workouts yeah
okay squat time one
two three you know what i mean like it's
the same track
he'll just flip the audio on the other
push up time
that's a great idea we should hit them
up free
your replies because i already did
[ __ ]
i did mess with him and the manager man
you're probably competing with all the
bots the hot bots hot
the hot bots look at any celebrity page
if you see
all the comments the first 10 comments
are like
hot bots that's true they're always like
porn yep
porn kind of i dare you to click my page
and then you go and it's like a only
fans
like okay actually you did they she
dared me they're me
she dared me
you